I wanna find our if our remote works. Oh.
Me too.
Okay. Um here's the agenda for our last meeting. Um after the opening we're going to have a prototype presentation, then we're going to discuss the evaluation criteria
Whoohoo.
and the financing of our remote. Then we're going to evaluate the product and I think the whole production process, and then we're gonna close it up, and
we have forty minutes, so let's get started. Oh, no, let's have the prototype presentation.
Mm 'kay, you ready?
Um sure. You or me?
Y you read that stuff, since you wrote it.
Okay. Well, since our materials aren't exactly what we were going for, I'm just gonna translate what this all means for you. The base is gonna be
I'll be the Vanna.
gunmetal gray, which is what we had decided, and it's gonna be plastic. Um then there's the latex cover, which is what you see as red.
Um because it can be replaceable, we just kinda went with the colour. Um and then the buttons are actually kind of poking through rather than on top.
Right.
Um and the buttons will be a l much lighter blue, almost see-through. It's just sort of a very pale blue and a light-up yellow. The whole thing
Hmm.
That's nice.
Yeah.
lights up if you press any button, rather than it just that one button will light up. Um and then at the bottom we have our logo. Um
Good.
bright yellow sort of design with the R_R_ which will actually look like our logo. And then on the side you have the buttons. They're one button, but
Great.
they kind of push up and down. I don't think they're scrolling.
Okay.
No.
They're just buttons.
Right, yeah. And then yeah, the buttons.
On off switch will be here and as you've noticed on our prototype um they've ended up with a curvature kind of, by concave sort of thing, except for
, you know, can't see underneath. So I'm hoping that when we get to production we can actually make them like that, because they're very nice to stock
Yeah.
you know, stick your finger in. Um the two squared buttons are are two probably least used, menu, mute, and then these are the numbers,
Thumb-shaped.
so our channel and our volume will be on either side.
Yeah. And then the last thing is just that it'll be black labelling on top, just which we didn't do.
Okay. And did you determine um the curvature of the bottom part of it for the hand, is it gonna be a single or a double?
I'd say a single.
Single. Single sounds good, 'cause it's not big enough to really constitute a double.
Single.
Yeah.
Right.
Yeah, it's only actually the size of my hand.
Great. Great. I think you did an awesome job. It is beautiful, and it's everything that we discussed.
Yeah, I think it's a beautiful Yeah. Good job, you guys. Those are really good.
Good job.
Oh thank you.
Whoohoo.
Alright what's next in our agenda?
Um we're gonna discuss the evaluation criteria, and that's with Courtney.
Okay, it's a PowerPoint presentation. I don't really know exactly what we should uh talk about. It's under evaluation.
Right.
Alright. Um so these are the criteria we're gonna ask, is it easy to use, is it fashionable uh yeah, I guess we should write these down
so we can reference them.
Mm.
Feel good meaning what? Physically, okay.
Like does it feel good, like yeah, physically.
Right.
Sqi
That's just for current trend. It doesn't really count, you guys.
Right.
Yeah, it was a little difficult to incorporate the cover with the cherry fruit on it.
Yeah. But it's so we do have removable covers, right? Yeah, well then that's covered. And so we n k everybody have that?
Right.
Yes.
'Kay.
I'll wait.
Yeah, she's got it. It's good. Yeah. Okay so, we're using the criteria uh for a seven point scale, and so we need to discuss
Yeah.
how we feel. It falls within this range, so for easy to use,
do we feel it's very easy to use?
Are we going to indi I say we individually rate what do you say? Just orally. Why not? We have okay. Um easy to use. I
True or false, easy to use.
You guys
Yeah.
Okay.
vote six.
Oh wait, that's false.
Oh, two.
Okay.
I'd say two as well.
Yeah, two.
Two. That's what I say. Okay, fashionable?
Uh hello, we're great.
Um one. No. Me too, very chic. One, I give it a one.
At the moment, no.
No. I mean like no, I think it's very fashionable. I thi I would give it a one.
Okay. I'll give it a two, because at the moment it's not looking that way.
Well, that's that's just like that's a clay, it's a prototype. What do you think?
Oh, and ma it's a prototype, right.
Mm I don't think it's that fashionable. I'd give it like three or four.
Well, now I'm. So, the average is about a two. Two or three. Two point five.
Okay.
Yeah, it's a two.
But then I'm not fashionable, so don't use my opinion.
That's okay. Yeah. Um
Neither are all o all the customers we have, either.
does it feel good?
Imagine, since we obviously don't have that.
I feel like
Does it feel good?
Uh the shape of it actually does uh.
And it's i it is very ergonomically designed. It's gonna be curved.
Yeah, it's gonna be thicker. Depth.
Yeah. I think so too. 'Kay. Two.
I think it feels good. I'll give it a two.
I'll give it a one.
What do you say?
I'd say a two.
Alright, average is two. Is it technologically innovative? Oh sorry I'm taking over your job here. Go right ahead.
Okay.
Oh no, it's fine, you're I mean you're Project Manager. Um yeah, I mean and it does it have voice I mean the phrase recognition on it
?
Yes. Right? We were able to do it with that kind of chip.
Oh right, the
We could do it with the chip, yes. It wasn't we have no reflection of it on the prototype, but that's because it's only two dimensions, really
And there's no way you can represent it on here. Y
Yeah, right. That was 'kay. And we discussed that being included.
.
Yeah, so. Then yes, then I would well it isn't what else would it need for it to be technologically innovative?
Right.
It
Well we don' have the you know, we can't say channel, and it changes the channel, channel eight.
And it doesn't cover anything other then T_V_, so I'd probably give it a three.
Right.
Yeah.
Okay.
Even though it is for just a T_V_ remote it's uh very advanced. But it is just a T_V_ remote.
Yeah. I'd go for a three or four on that one, so okay, let's go for a three point five.
Yeah I go four.
Three and an half.
Alright, and the last criteria is it is it um Well, we've covered that with the trendy.
Squishy and fruity. It's just trendy, basically.
Well yeah, so I'd give it a two.
It's capable of being squishy and fruity.
Sure. Capable. Very capable.
Oh, it's very capable of being squishy and fruity.
Okay.
And it's very important. 'Kay, there we go. So. Next.
Yeah.
Okay, next.
So um our re model slightly resembling a giant delicious cookie appears to be a winner, and uh hopefully we'll sell millions. Good job, team.
How did you get that in there? The slightly resembling a giant delicious cookie. That was good.
What?
It it does. Thanks.
It does. Very good. Alright, let's go back to this
No, that's it. Hmm.
Oops.
Okay, so now uh we're moving on to finance, okay. I'm gonna show you an Excel spreadsheet and we're going to fill it in together based on what
components we're including in our remote and see if it's under twelve fifty Euro. If so, we can proceed, if not, we need to go back to
the drawing board a little bit. 'Kay? So let me bring that up.
Here we go. Alright. Um it's not hand dynamo, it's powered by battery, so we give it a Number of components you plan to use. Do
Yep.
Two.
I just put quantity being one battery, or Yeah. But if it's a do you wanna go for this is where we need to make a final call on
Yeah.
Mm 'kay.
if it's a lithium or do we wanna go triple A_s, 'cause triple A_s we're gonna have t do more than one battery. Oh, let's just go for
a lithium. What do you say? I think uh I think the people who purchase this are gonna be technologically right. Okay, down to the electronics um
Yeah, let's let's do a lithium. We're gon that's gon
Yeah, it's.
Nologically advanced, yeah.
section. We're gonna need this kind, correct, if we do the voice sensor, so one of those. It is a single-curved, so one of those
Yeah.
Yep.
. Oh. What's that? Yeah, that's correct. 'Kay, down here, case material. Plastic.
Uh.
Yeah.
It's plastic.
We plastic.
And special colour.
'Kay.
Down here, interface type. We're gonna have the integrated scroll scroll wheel. Isn't oh those are just regular buttons.
No, we don't have the scroll. Buttons.
But it's
Well, that's the push-button too, right there.
Yeah, but i so i
This?
Integrated scroll-wheel or push-button. We're really having just push-button interface.
Okay, so we can just go um.
But will we w actually we'll need two, won't we? One for the top and then one for the s one e for each side.
But it that just covers the type of button we're having. Because we're not doing a scroll on the side, it's still push-button.
Oh like the twenty nine means like you have both scrolls and push-buttons. But we don't have any scrolls.
Push-button. But we just have push
Okay.
Right I think she's I think what Courtney's talking about is do we need to put two here?
Like because there's like one interface right here and then because it's not gonna be on the same plane when you press the button. There's gonna have to be additional
Right.
Yeah. Okay.
signals on the sides. So is that gonna be an extra one on each side?
I don't know, they might put us well, let's just. Two or would it be three?
Two interfaces, is that what w should we s say?
Let's call it th
Or three, because of one on each side and one on top. I mean it's fine 'cause it comes out the same as twenty nine. Well less than
Okay, fine. Yeah.
twenty nine even.
Okay.
Okay and we're gonna button supplements the buttons are no uh okay.
They're a special colour. Um they're uh they're a special form, 'cause they're indented.
Are they? Oh, right.
And then s yeah.
And, they're a special material.
Mm. Well, we're under cost then. Alright. No, we're under. Twelve point five is our limit. We've got eleven point two. Alright.
We're over? Okay. Oh, I see.
Grand.
We're under.
So we can go to production.
We can go to
I dunno what I just did.
Okay. Now we're gonna talk about the project process um and whether or not we're satisfied with the whole process and the result. Um did we have a lot
of room for creativity? Did we have a lot of room for individual leadership, um teamwork, and the means, meaning the technology that we used to produce
our little guy there, and if we found any new ideas. Now, question is, how do we do this?
Go back. Previous.
I think we just discuss it.
Discuss, sure. Alright. Who want who would like to go first?
We think we got stifled for cri creativity by the company itself, in restricting us only to using a T_V_ remote, initially.
We didn't have a whiteboard.
Hmm. Hmm.
Yeah. And no internet.
Oh that's true.
Yeah.
No, yeah, that's a good point. 'Cause I'd forgotten that that wasn't our decision, yeah.
And how did you feel about the whole the whole process though?
Oh, overall I mean I thought we did a good job like We got to choose basically we had control over minus it being just merely a T_V_ remote we
got to choose what we wanted to do with it.
Right, and we got say over what how technologically advanced it should be and also how fashionable, which I kind of like we yep. You know it.
And we're a fashion forward technology company.
right.
Um what about um the teamwork aspect? How did you guys enjoy making the model, the prototype?
I think we did well.
Yeah.
I think ya' did. Did you work well together in there, and 'kay.
Yep.
Well, no, there was there was scratching and fighting, but no.
Minus that one fight. Yeah.
Oh my God, and we've all been a pretty congenial team here, I think. We hadn't had any ma fallings out.
Gouges.
Yeah. I mean minus you guys being wha what is it, the survey, annoying or what is it? Irritating, yeah. Wow that's a it's definitely
Irritating.
a strong one.
Okay.
The means, the whiteboard didn't work.
And no internet.
Yeah.
Yeah. I have to knock that one down a couple notches.
Yeah, and no internet.
A and our friend here really feels strongly about the internet.
Misses. I do. There's so much available. Like it's information
And the digital the digital pens were they were pretty cool. Yeah they were fun, even though I'm not really sure what I could do with them, but
Yeah, digital pens. They were fine.
I really appreciated those, yeah.
they are awesome.
The use of the laptops for receiving everything. It was wireless too, so.
Yeah.
Right, laptops are extremely handy, wireless. And that we have a shared network where we can put all of the
And these things whoa.
Yeah.
And let's not forget the sexy dual microphones everyone gets to wear.
Yeah. And Big Brother.
Big brother.
Yeah.
'Kay, have we found any new ideas through this process?
Um we are really gonna sell this. Ta-da.
For something that looks cool and also has what I want it to b do technologically. And that's your right brain taking over, w wanting the artistic, the
Yeah.
fashionable, the hip, you know. If we all just went out and bought useful things, I don't think I mean that's not what technology.
Mm-hmm.
Well, that's why I don't like uh Macs or Apples, just 'cause I look at it, and I know it's probably a very good computer, but I
look at it, and I'm taken back to elementary school, 'cause they look the same. They look like they did when I was in elementary school, and
Mm.
Yeah.
Yeah, 'cause they're pretty and just like
that's so old-fashioned to me.
The Toronto district school would only use his Macs with their kids.
Yeah.
Exactly, so I associate them with like really low-tech, really cheap, bad Yeah.
Yeah. Just the Mac font bothers me even. But I do like iPods, go figure.
Uh yeah.
Yeah, no, iPods They want all those words for presentation, even the plugs.
Yeah.
Well, i iPods are now quite trendy, and they come in different colours. Yeah.
Mm-hmm. Colours. Exactly. I mean how many people went out and bough a Nokia phone, back when we were like in high school, just so they
could get the changeable face plates. Okay. Anyway, so that is definitely at work.
Oh yeah, everybody.
Not me. I didn't have a phone 'til university.
Mine is amber. Oh.
But the my but my one issue is just like the whole it's for T_V_ only. I was like who's gonna buy a remote just for the T_V_ unless they've
lost theirs.
Look at it. That is a piece of work. Wow. Marketing Director says yeah. Fashionable people will buy it.
Yeah. Fashionable chic people will.
You're kidding.
No, no. No, marketing has to actually create the desire for it.
Oh, I will create desire.
That's okay. We can create a commercial where they think that all their needs will be met. This will help them find the one. That's right.
Ri They'll be sexy with it.
Hmm.
We could have like an Adam and Eve type commercial, and that's the fig-leaf. Mm. That'll sell.
Oh right.
There you go, marketing.
Let you loose.
And so the serpent says, use our remote.
Yeah. Yeah.
Alright. Okay, we're gonna wrap this up now. Um the costs are within the budget, we evaluated the project, and now we're gonna complete the final
Yeah, no.
questionnaire and meeting summary, and then we're going to have a big giant party, apparently, according to this, so. Alright, thank you team, you
Whoohoo. Margaritas for everyone.
did a great job, it was lovely working with you.
Good.
You too.
Yay. Thanks to the Project Leader.
Now we know w